(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
YOU GUYS ENJOY BUYING USELESS
PRODUCTS THAT ARE MADE BY THE
CRIMINALLY INSANE, THEN ETSY IS
FOR YOU!
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU GUYS
STRANGE ITEMS FROM ETSY AND FOR
250 POINTS YOU HAVE TO GIVE
ME A KILLER TAG LINE TO HELP
SELL IT.
ALL RIGHT HERE IS THE FIRST ONE.
THIS FELT RABBIT NECKLACE.
(LAUGHTER)
YES, ROB DELANEY.
>> IF YOUR VIRGINITY IS IN
JEOPARDY, JUST THROW THIS ON.
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS
FOR THAT.
YES, TOMMY JOHNAGIN.
>> THAT'S FOR THE WOMAN IN YOUR
LIFE THAT YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
IN YOUR LIFE ANYMORE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: PLEASE GO AWAY.
TOMMY JOHNAGIN, POINTS.
>> I LOVE THAT IT HAS 1,200
REVIEWS, AND THEY'RE ALL FIVE
STARS, I LOOKED AT THEM.
>> Chris: ARE THEY?
>> I SWEAR TO GOD.
>> Chris: THEY REALLY ARE,
THEY'RE ALL FIVE STARS.
I WONDER WHAT THE--
>> MASS SUICIDE IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE?
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE,
TRAVESTY IN A TEACUP.
(LAUGHTER)
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
YES, ROB DELANEY.
>> START YOUR DAY OFF RIGHT WITH
A STEM CELL SMOOTHIE, CHUNKY
STYLE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: I KNOW THE CROWD WAS
WITH YOU AT THE BEGINNING AND
THEN THEY GOT A LITTLE UPSET,
BUT I DO BLAME, I DO BLAME THIS,
I DON'T KNOW, POINTS OR NO
POINTS?
>> POINTS!
>> Chris: YOU GET POINTS.
THE AUDIENCE SAYS POINTS.
STEM CELL SMOOTHIE CHUNKY STYLE.
ALI WONG.
>> HONEY WE'RE OUT OF COFFEE, I
THINK IT IS TIME FOR PLAN B.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS, ALI WONG!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> I HATE TO DO THIS BUT THAT
LOOKS JUST LIKE MY DAUGHTER.
(LAUGHTER)
SHE IS SO CUTE.
>> Chris: I DON'T KNOW IF I'M
SUPPOSED TO GIVE YOU POINTS FOR
THAT OR NOT BUT IT MADE ME LAUGH
SO I WILL GIVE YOU POINTS, TOMMY
JOHNAGIN.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
NEXT ONE, LOOK AT THIS LEATHER
DOLL BABY.
(LAUGHTER)
YES, TOMMY, PLEASE DON'T SAY
THAT LOOKS LIKE YOUR DAUGHTER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THIS IS A GREAT DOLL TO SIT
OUTSIDE BARBIE'S DREAM HOUSE IN
A WINDOWLESS VAN.
(LAUGHTER)